-The show is fantastic.
This is really exciting,
David Simon, George Pelecanos
are the co-creators.
David Simon did "The Wire,"
and this is
a really exciting show
that takes place in New York
in the ´70s.
-Yes.
-You were here in New York then.
You were a kid.
-Not in ´71.
-Okay, not in ´71.
-[ Laughs ] No.
-But you were here back
when it was a little dirtier
than now.
-I was.
-What were your memories of 42nd
and 2nd and that sort of
Times Square area?
-Well, I came here
to go to college.
-Uh-huh.
-I went to Columbia in ´95.
I mean, Times Square, by then,
was already kind of like the way
it is now, wasn´t it?
-Yeah, but I feel like I --
The first time I came
to New York was ´95,
and I still feel like it was
almost now
with, like,
four porno shops left.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that´s true. That´s true.
-Which was really jarring.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-That´s true, the combination.
-´Cause you´re like, "Hmm,
am I gonna get a coffee
or go into a weird booth
for an hour"? So, yeah.
-That´s true, that´s true.
I remember, actually, this is
more about, like, way over
on the West Side
in the West Village. There was
a -- there was, I think,
a porn shop called "Harmony."
-Oh, that´s lovely.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought it was
a health food store.
-Harmony does sound more like
-I did walk into it one day
thinking it was
a health food store.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
You were like, these are not
granola bars.
[ Laughter ]
I also want to compliment
your wig in that scene.
-Thank you so much.
-And this was a wig
you selected, yes?
-Yes, well, we did the, like,
the camera test which usually
have had conversations
with people before.
-Yeah.
-And you know, you have an idea
of what you want to do,
but like, they hadn´t hired
a hair woman yet.
-Uh-huh.
-So I get there and there´s like
20 blonde wigs and they looked
okay, and then I saw one
that was, like, uh, I mean,
to be totally honest,
I think it maybe was like
a dime store clown wig
or something.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And -- But I went --
Okay, I don´t want that wig,
but I want to look like
Bernadette Peters
or like Hanna Schygulla from the
Fassbender movies or something,
and I went -- or like,
my character´s name is Candy.
I wanted to look like -- like
cotton candy, like yummy.
-Yeah.
-You know? And so I put
that wig on for the camera test,
and everyone got freaked out,
and then I convinced them,
you know, and then we got
a really good one made.
Actually, I´ve been seeing
Edie Falco
on the side of buses
with my wig on.
-Yeah. It´s very similar.
You´re right.
She´s in -- it´s like
a Menendez brothers show,
and she has your wig.
-Do you know what
I´m talking about?
-Yeah, I do.
I´ve seen it on buses, too.
Do you think it´s the same wig
and they´re just running it
from set to set?
[ Laughter ]
-I´m going to text her
that I want my wig back.
-[ Laughs ] I want your...
So you play -- this is about --
you play a sex worker
who then becomes --
starts directing adult films
´cause this is about
the legalization
of the pornography industry.
And you actually --
is it true that you went
and found sex workers
who worked in New York
at that time and talked to them?
-Yes.
Before we shot the pilot, I was,
like, getting ready to do it
and I realized I had so many
questions I didn´t have any way
to answer unless I actually
talked to a sex worker.
So I asked Nina Noble, who´s
the third in the triumvirate
of David Simon,
George Pelecanos,
and Nina is the sort
of behind the scenes
other element in that group.
I said, like, I need to talk
to a sex worker,
and she found me Annie Sprinkle,
who was a prostitute
in the early ´70s
and then got into porn,
and she´s kind of like
an intellectual pornographer.
-That´s very -- that´s probably
the perfect person to find
to talk to for something
like this.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
She´s like a sex activist
and she´s hot and she´s funny
and she, you know, she answered
all of the, like,
real down and dirty questions
I had.
-What is -- because I think
we´re on late enough at night
for me to say this, but...
[ Laughter ]
...what sort of down and dirty
questions did you ask?
-Well, I was like, first of all,
how many men a night?
-Yeah, I guess
that would be one.
-So she said like 8 to 10.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-That´s really crazy.
-Well, right,
so if that´s your reality
and it´s really 8 to 10 men
a night,
then who are you
and how do you manage that,
and you know, what does that
actually feel like
and if you´re telling the story
of that woman as opposed
to the "Pretty Woman" version
of this story, you know,
how do you make sure
to tell the truth?
And you know, so I had questions
like that.
I said, "well, what do you do if
it´s really, really cold?"
"Uh, do you wax, you know?"
-Yeah.
-It was like...So, she was
incredibly helpful.
She also introduced me to a lot
of her friends,
so I ended up talking to many
women in their 60s and 70s
who had been involved in, like,
the early days of porn,
which was particularly cool
because, you know, I think,
some people as they get older,
get wiser and more interesting.
-Yeah. I´m sure in reflecting
back on it has a lot more value
putting the years between it.
Did they -- were they happy
that the show was being made,
that this story was being told
this way
as opposed
to the "Pretty Woman" way?
-Yeah, I think so.
I think a lot of people,
you know, from what I can tell
from Twitter,
sex workers who have tweeted
with me,
I think they´re waiting to see.
-Oh, well, that´s fair.
-And I think that´s smart.
And I think that -- I hope that
they´ll feel respected and
pleased with what we´re doing.
-I´m guessing it´ll probably
just be the wig
if they have an issue.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "you know,
we wouldn´t pick that wig."
Um...
-[ Laughs ]